did you have any racist friends growing
up or anybody not the two drop any name
so did you experience this one guy rick
he was busy
i'm serious with you like yeah i mean
there's some yes okay so i did as well i
was in south carolina in the army and i
went out and uh
my dad came to see me for graduation so
we went into south carolina if you know
south carolina what is capital for
capital south carolina is
you know you guys are literally a
confederate flag exactly that's what i'm
saying to you so i went out i'm like oh
wow there's some of this taking place
where are you from and i was
no hair at that time i mean bald it's
not the friendliest look i got right so
i'm walking around and people are
looking at me i'm having i'm like why
these guys really do look at me as a
threat coming from iran
but i will tell you what concerns me
about what you just said
so this weekend uh we went shopping in
miami with the kids i took tikko and
dylan because i went to a birthday party
that the boys weren't invited because
you have to be three to five to go to
the birthday party and they didn't
qualify because they're eight or nine so
mommy kicked us out she went to the
birthday party with babies and i said
let's go shopping
we go to miami it's me tico dillon and
sam and
tico says daddy can we get some gelato i
said uh well let's see how you guys
gonna behave and we'll get some gelato
and believe me i want some gelato myself
so i want to go get some gelato because
that is going to happen
and then
tico makes a comment he says daddy
you're such a fun destroyer i said i'm a
what you're a fun destroyer i said no
problem i said perfect i said tico let
me teach you a lesson about life if you
tell me i'm a fun destroyer i'm going to
act like a fun destroyer because you
made me believe as a father i'm a fun
destroyer so we go can we get gelato no
i'm a fun destroyer i'm committed to
being a fun destroyer so we walk we go
to nike i can't believe you're doing
this daddy i i didn't mean it i said no
i believe it now because you said it
with so much conviction i believe i'm a
fun destroyer so i'm going to be
committed for being a fun destroyer for
an hour and a half i play the role of a
fun destroyer make sense played it well
so i said to him i said so can you
explain to me uh uh do you understand
why it's so powerful i said have you
dylan have you ever heard me call you a
loser no why
i don't know because i'm not yeah
because if i call you you believe it
because you're not a loser i'll call you
a loser i said if you call me a fun
destroyer as a father i think i'm a fun
destroyer as a father maybe i become a
fun destroyer as a father then tico is
like oh that's starting to make sense so
let's play a game together so what's
that
tico what can he say good about dylan
what are some good things about dylan i
think dylan is smart i think dylan is
this i think dylan has i said dylan how
about you about tico he says well daddy
tico sometimes doesn't share the games
with me i said no no only good so
dylan's trying to make an effort to say
something good about his brother they
had a big fight this morning in the
house which was epic anyways
by the time it was then i said tico did
my point make sense he says yeah daddy
you're definitely not a fun distressor
tell me why i'm not a fun destroyer he
says you always wrestle with us you
always do this i say okay so the meaning
of fun story you have to be very careful
using that word because words have
weight right they carry a lot of weight
if you tell a
eight-year-old kid
you're racist because of your lineage
dude i can only imagine if somebody
tells that to me 50 40 100 times i'm
gonna start believing it now you're
giving birth to a generation that grow
up
hating their own lineage i look
you read the bible and see what happened
to syrians one of the greatest famines
about assyrians 180 something thousand
right god wasn't a big fan of assyrians
if you read some of the history of what
they did because they thought they could
be bigger than god and they built this
empire to go up there and if you don't
know the history of assyrians they're
very interesting people right assyrians
but guess what what are we going to sit
there and say oh because of that
let me tell you
you are you know
you're responsible for that no that's
what they did but people change and we
can get better and you just have to be
careful to not put me in a box that just
because i'm that i'm doing that as well
so very surprising virginia told us
that to parents
voting for your side of the aisle is
less important than voting for how your
kids are raised exactly that was a very
big indicator so very good point you
just made
on that part so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you